Please welcome, oh my God,
I can't believe I'm saying this, Norah O'Donnell.
(audience applauding)
(laughing)
Okay, I'm fan-girling you Right back my friend.
Oh my gosh, I can't, I watch you every night.
This is so surreal and so crazy
and you came on a very important day,
the start of cake week and the week long,
we're shining a light on special cake in the news,
actually, cake of the day.
Let's try this animation.
♪ Cake of the day ♪
Whoa!
Yeah, she's cute.
And today it's the Smith Island cake
from Smith Island, Maryland
and like you made the cake last night.
(laughs) Well, look, I knew that this was gonna be
the cake of the day and I thought really the only cake
that people in Maryland cared about were crab cakes,
(audience laughing)
but it turns out the official dessert of Maryland
is the Smith Island cake
and so I was like, all right, I got to know what this is.
So last night, what did I do?
I got Grace, we got the pans.
We went to the grocery store and here it is.
And so I can report to you,
it's a lot of work making,
it was supposed to be eight layers,
only seven turned out well, but we made it
and I had cake for breakfast so thank you, Drew. (laughs)
Aww, I love that and it's a cake
that launched a thousand ships because for 200 years,
fishermen took this cake made by their wives,
usually on their annual oyster harvest
and the fudge like kept it together
and congealed without going bad when they were out
on the boat for a long time
so that's the interesting fun fact about that.
Now, speaking of food, you're married to Jeff Tracy,
and he is an amazing restaurateur.
He owns six restaurants in Washington, DC.
You guys got married in 2004, is that correct?
2001, we were actually,
and we've been together since we were in college.
So we've actually I think-
That's right, you met at Georgetown?
Yeah, so it's gonna be 20 years married,
I guess in 2021 and we got together when I was 17
and I'm gonna to turn 47 this year.
At this point, we're in it for the long haul.
(laughing)
I mean, what is your advice to people?
I always ask on this show, I'm sorry,
this wasn't part of the pre-interview,
but I'm always so curious.
What is good advice for the long haul?
You know, because we live in a society where swipe left,
swipe left, everybody's a little ADD
and not investing as much,
or knowing that they have the option to be free.
And so, they sometimes get out.
What do you think is the recipe for knowing
you can make it through the long haul?
It's a good question.
I mean, the advice my mom had always given me
was try and marry your best friend,
marry someone who respects his own mother,
and his mother and treats her well.
And then I think what's kind of kept us together is just,
we try and do things together.
Like, in college, we used to say
a couple of studies together, stays together.
Now, we kind of try and take a walk every morning,
if we can just non pressured time together,
play golf together, something like that.
So you can just catch up
and then there's a lot of forgiveness involved
in any relationship. (laughs)
I love that, I just heard this,
it was a "Friday Night Lights" quotes,
like there's no sinning and forgiving
and I was like, yes, I so agree.
Now we're gonna go to a commercial break
and come back and do some feel good stories
and something I just wanna say is that I know that you are
the Managing Editor of the "CBS Evening News".
So you are really the grand conductor of the content
and I know that it was a mission of yours to make sure
that you balance the stuff we all must know
to do our civic duties and be informed citizens
of the world but you also felt that it was important
to give stories of hope and functionality.
I always say that word just because,
why was that so important to you?
Yeah and I think you said that well.
It's like being a conductor
and you have to have a great orchestra and team,
which we really do have at CBS news
and the evening news and part of what I said
is we cover a lot of the hard news every day,
but we have to do hard news and then do heart
and so we really try and cover stories
that capture our common humanity.
We did a story earlier this year about The Soupman.
His name is Peter Kelleher, up in New Hampshire
and New England, he's all over.
He lost his son to opioid addiction
who then became homeless.
You know what he did?
He got a school bus and now he goes around
and feeds soup to homeless people
and gives them socks and toiletries
and so we went one day and helped him deliver soup.
We did a story on Bitty & Beau's Coffee.
A lot of people may know them.
They now employ hundreds of people with special needs
and the woman who started it, Amy Wright,
she has two kids, Bitty & Beau who have down syndrome.
And she was like, where are they gonna work?
You know what's their future?
Why don't we create a coffee shop
where special needs people can work
and it's the best coffee and the most amazing
and beautiful people you've ever met in your life
and so those are kind of the stories
we're trying to highlight every night on the evening news,
because my mom always said to me,
if you capture someone's heart, you capture their mind.
And so that's the one thing I say,
every story we do, even the hard news stories,
make sure we tell people's humanity in them.
And you use the word tone repeatedly
in some of the things you've said in public
about how you conduct your symphony of the news
and I so agree.
As like a filmmaker, I always thought
tone was my parameters.
If I cared about the tone and the heart,
everything else, the comedy, the action, like whatever,
it would all work out around it
(upbeat music)